[Musik]
frage 7 32 und max nach berlin kam es
heute nacht davon geträumt freunde
tatsächlich auch immer in meiner tür
geklopft um in den taten gemacht
[Musik]
als gewählt wer aber wird eine frau
opfer geschickt was eigentlich dazu ist
aber nicht nur ausdruck finde ich auch
noch auf dem pulli geschlossen hat
[Musik]
regnet ich bin gerade jemand und es war
angekommen
tatsächlich an der plan ist auf jeden
fall dafür und ganz kurz frisch machen
und da werden wir die briten hotel
[Musik]
reguliert dement rechnung bekommen wir
wollten auch vorbereiten
und ist aber noch nicht da was man
gelernt welche klausur hier irgendwie
wir stehen jetzt gerade auf brücken in
berlin und der fängt an zu regnen
[Musik]
was mich jetzt auf jeden fall zu zweit
unterwegs und verfolgt er wie gelähmt
hier kommt meine damen und herren max
hat natürlich immer beschützen gefragt
wir laufen jetzt auf jeden fall in das
gelände hier kann man abends feiern und
essen fotos machen oder dienstleistung
sinnvoll das machen der großen ring
bekommt
[Musik]
wer mit bleibt mal eine pause gemacht
und luca will etwas zu trinken holen
passt schon gar nicht so dass die leute
in deutschland rückspiel gruppen
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal zusammen mit
pfarrer aber okay ich habe jetzt einfach
mal so ein asia lebensmittelladen
rausgesucht schon einige zeit vergangen
und mit dunkler
im heute angekommen
und schon alles irgendwie gerade nicht
normal
ich wollte alles verkaufen was da vorne
jetzt vorbei mir scheint das nicht so
ganz normal
die leute ich glaube es wird zeit für
mein neues outfit
[Musik]
wasser kaufen
gucken
plus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wieder gewonnen
herzlichen glückwunsch zum zweiten mal
heute abend
bei schönen fußtritten je nach der
gefühlten niederlage heute abend ich bin
übrigens sogar nicht gewinnen immer
solche wieder samstags ist ein
ja warum das letzte stück besser
[Musik]
so leute das zweite ist auch hier vom
heutigen blog ich bin nicht hier und
heute mal angekommen den tag heute
weiter und rennstrecke deswegen freue
ich mich in unserem lachen
dieser findet sich auf jeden fall sagen
wir sehen uns morgen wir bereits schon
mitbekommen habe freunde geht es hier um
den neuen spiderman homecoming film und
war an der stelle noch mal danke und
auch nicht so coole kooperationen und
verwendet ihr jetzt mal unten in die
infobox schaut findet ihr dort ein
gewinnspiel und wackelt über diesem
gewinnspiel ein meet and greet mit mir
und dem hauptdarsteller tom rowland in
berlin am kleinflecken gewinn also
checkt die info box aus und haut rein
[Musik]